Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy
New Year it sounds like we actually have
the first official casting news for the
new Avatar The Last Airbender Netflix
series so we'll break it down if you're
brand new to my channel I'll be doing
avatar bonus videos until the new series
gets here so be sure to subscribe to get
everything George DeNoto one of the actors who
played a version of the Jett character
in the infamous live-action avatar the
last airbender movie says that he's
going to be playing a character probably
Jett in the new upcoming Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix series in a bid to
redeem himself for the awful awful
live-action movie the reason we found
out about this is because he flat-out
posted it to his Twitter account he has
a ton of followers I don't know whether
or not he was authorized to do this or
if he's going to get in trouble for doing
it but I'm glad that he did because Mike
and Bryan have been very very quiet
about what's going on right now with the
casting process for the new Netflix
series according to Jessi flowers the
person who played Toph on the original
Avatar The Last Airbender series they're
going to start shooting sometime in
February but just a couple weeks ago
everyone was posting waiting for updates
on the new series and he responded to
someone's post saying for everyone
asking yes I will be playing a role in
this series and will do my best to
rewrite the wrong I made by playing a
role in the previous last airbender
movie I don't know what he hopes to be
forgiven for hopefully he wasn't bullied
as a child for just being in this movie
little kids don't have control over that
kind of thing he was a very young child
when he did the movie version of this
Jett Zuko Iroh scene from the beginning
of book 2 where they're all going to Ba
Sing se and meet up for the first time
telling each other about their
backstories the movie yadda-yadda-yadda
its way through the book one story so
there was no room for an actual full
blown Jett character but when he says
he's trying to redeem his performance it
implies is getting a second crack at the
character meaning a much more accurate
version of Jett from the original series
and it makes sense
they've got potentially four to five
seasons hopefully more than that in 40
to 50 hours to tell the story if not
more there'd be way more room for more
accurate versions of all the side
characters the Harry Potter movies are a
really good example of this too they got
eight movies all of them very long
tell the story of seven books and they
still had to cut out a ton of the book
story I feel like you either like or you
hate the Jett character there's not a
whole lot of in-between the way they
used him he was mostly introduced to
give some character development to the
Sokka character and to be a romantic
rival for Aang really early in the story
before Zuko showed up and they did their
whole zoo tarah storyline so when people
typically think of Aang's romantic
rivals for Katara's affections they
typically think of Zuko in zoo Terra
stuff but here's my top 10 Jett
moments from the original series
starting with number 10 sokka's instincts are terrible the whole
episode is just this big arc for Sokka
to start taking charge and being more of
a leader in the group because he thinks
of himself as the oldest character even
though Aang has both of them beat by
almost a hundred years right off the bat
sokka's instincts are terrible they use
it for a lot of comedy with anga tarah
teasing him they also sort of set up the
Jets storyline too with Katara teasing
him that he's never kissed a girl
Sokka was fifteen at the start of Avatar
The Last Airbender Katara was 14 in Aang
was technically a hundred and twelve
years old but because he was frozen in
the ice when he was 12
developmentally when he comes out he
acts like he's 12 for most of book 1
although he does the most growing up of
any character on the series the youngest
character winds up being the most mature
by the finale
number 9 jet swoops in saves them with
his hook swords making him Katara's
first official crush right after she
spent the entire first part of the
episode teasing Sokka about this
I'm sure Sokka totally kissed a girl she
just lives in another nation please
don't try and contact her she's super
busy and won't be able to answer you but
number 8 this is actually kind of funny
Jed is basically Rufio from the hook
movie living with his own group of Lost
Boys in their own super cool tree fort
that terrorized their own version of
Captain Hook in the form of the Fire
Nation people, like how 'bout a mohawk.
now, how bout' not one mohawk how about three Mohawks. And you're like... Rufio as you all
know was played by a very young Dante
Basco during the 90s who would later go
on to become Prince Zuko for Avatar The
Last Airbender when that series began he
also came back during Legend of Korra as
Zuko's grandson general Iroh named after
uncle Iroh and that he will be returning for the
new live-action Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix series but we don't
know who he's going to be playing in the
new series not Zuko because he's
obviously much older now but probably
some important Fire Nation character I
know a lot of you are really hoping that
he plays cabbage man or foaming mouth
guy or something funny we'll see if they
don't announce it before the series
he'll probably just show up it'll be
some huge surprise but the whole thing
with the Jett character is that he's
meant to be the stabbier darker version
of Sokka so Sokka has this big arc in
the episode where he goes from being
really immature to growing up a lot by
the end saving the Fire Nation people
and within the story of hook Rufio is
meant to be the stabbier version of
Peter Pan number 7 jett winds up being
this crazed tyrant who almost kills an
innocent man from the Fire Nation
until Sokka stops him later he even
concocts the lie about the old man
having the dagger of poison being sent
to kill him the whole thing with him in
the tribe of little kids that are trying
to be freedom fighters seems pretty
genuine it's just that Jett has gone so
overboard with his desire for revenge
it's just that they wrote the Jett
characters so hardcore so that Sokka
would realize a lot of his inner rage
and desire for revenge against Fire
Nation people wasn't his place oh just
because a Fire Nation soldier was
responsible for the death of my mother
doesn't mean that all the Fire Nation
people deserve to die
number 6 Jett reveals he's going to blow up
the dam without caring that he'll caused
the deaths of countless innocent Fire
Nation people women and children the
same old man that Sokka just saved in
Eng Katara don't want to hear anything
bad about jett because Aang is having so
much fun in the tree fort and Katara
still pretty smitten with Jett so number
5 he tries to make Katara and Aang
complicit and killing all the Fire Nation town by lying to them in order to
get them to help he even tries to kill
Aang by swiping his glider just as he's
taking off the clip and then attacks both of them Mike and Bryan said there
were always a lot of really weird rules
that Nickelodeon had about how hardcore
they could get with some of these scenes
but even though Aang is an airbender and
technically he wasn't in any real danger
in this moment because he is the avatar
his Avatar state would have automatically kicked in to save him if
he fell off the cliff Jett did not know
that when he swiped the glider he was
just trying to stop him from saving the
dam at any cost so there are a couple of
genuine moments where he starts fighting
them and goes after them with his swords
even going after Katara but number 4
this is actually probably a bigger
he stole guitar first kiss in a deleted scene from book
1 episode 10 he never actually aired
this during broadcast and it's not on
the blu-ray extras but later during the
official avatar extras bonus features
they did confirm that Jett really was
Katara's first official kiss from a boy
in the group did spend the rest of the
series teasing her about Jett being her
boyfriend through book two when he came
back into the story
Katara didn't really start thinking of
Aang romantically in a serious way till
the end of book three their kiss
was in the finale right after he
defeated fire lord sozin even though he
had been crushing on her since book 1
number 3 Zuko and Iroh vs. Jett so
during book 2 Jett came back to the
story trying to move to bossing say with
the freedom fighters in the earth nation
for a chance for a better life and ran
into Zuko and Iroh by coincidence he
tried and failed to get Zuko to join his
freedom fighters and then turned on them
when he saw Iroh firebending his tea. Tea, one of iroh's two main weaknesses tea and
pretty girls he then spent the next couple of episodes trying to out them to
the authorities flat out fighting them
without ever realizing how important
they were he just knew that they were
firebenders when he started going after
them he didn't know that they were two
princes of the Fire Nation so number two
of course Jett gets captured by the Dai
Li and taken under Lake laogai for a
quote-unquote re-education calm down
you're safe now
there is no war in Ba Sing se that was
also the episode with the Judy reveal I
think when you consider all of his story
line through avatar people like this
version of Jett in these episodes better
than the book one version of Jett just
because book 1 episode 10 is not one of
the best episodes of the series in the
number one of course Jett dies r.i.p
Jett you'll mostly be known as Katara's
first crush in Aang's romantic rival he
did kind of redeem himself at the end by
trying to help them find Appa who by
that time had made it to Ba Sing se and
was being held under the lake but it
actually wound up being Zuko that saved
Appa Mike and Bryan also explained big
from behind the scenes nickelodeon
as a network was so hardcore about them
never showing the Jett had been killed
by the Dai Li and they never let them
reference it in an overt discreet way in
later episodes there were some offhand
remarks and implications during the
ember island players episode when they
were doing that part of their story
to play I feel like if you watch the
episode even if you're a little kid when
you saw it you probably thought that jett
died during this moment but Nickelodeon
is just really weird about the way they
show stuff like that
so let me know in the comments what do
you think about them including jett in
the new live-action Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix series they're
supposed to serve filming around
February like I said next month so we'll
pry start hearing more official casting
news soon as soon as they start
releasing more official information I'll
be sure to include it in my future
Avatar The Last Airbender videos but let
me know in the comments what you want my
next avatar video to be about you may
have heard they also recently revealed
what the story was going to be for
Avatar The Last Airbender book 4 if the
series hadn't have stopped after book 3
before the live-action movie ramped up
click here to learn about that it's very Azula heavy, and click here for all my
other avatar the last airbender Netflix
teaser and trailer videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome Happy New Year!